der bundestagspräsident wolfgang
schäuble hat ja eigentlich an laschet
quasi selber sozusagen befördert als
kanzlerkandidat gegen ihren parteichef
söder und jetzt verliert er seinen job
ihr das ist doch ein bisschen ironie
dabei oder naja gut also am ende hat der
wähler entschieden dass die spd stärker
ist und das prinzip sagt die stärkste
fraktion stellt den
bundestagspräsidenten und damit ist auch
diese entscheidung vorprogrammiert ich
habe seit 1972 hier im deutschen
bundestag absoluter rekordhalter wird
auch die ansprache halten bei der
konstituierenden sitzung aber wird nicht
mehr bundestagspräsident sein er ist
wieder direkt gewählt worden in seinem
wahlkreis und der wird natürlich gleich
auch in diese fraktionssitzung kommen
und wir alle sind ja sehr gespannt was
da passiert
alexander dobrindt der gerade frisch
gewählt wurde der diese wahl leitet sagt
bisher liegt ihm kein anderer vorschlag
vor die csu scheint unbedingt reif
brinkhaus heute bestätigen zu wollen
warum naja was wir unbedingt brauchen
ist nach so einer wahl wie nach jeder
wahl übrigens erst mal stabilität und
handlungsfähigkeit
also die landesgruppe die fraktion muss
jetzt handlungsfähig sein um eventuelle
koalitionsgespräche sondierungen was
auch immer auf uns zukommen könnte auch
zu
durchführen zu können wir haben heute in
der landesgruppe der csu den
landesgruppenvorsitzenden mit einer
klaren mehrheit gewählt bei uns wird er
für vier jahre gewählt in der fraktion
wird nur für ein jahr erst mal gewählt
und das steht jetzt an also wichtig ist
immer gerade nach einer wahl dass man
noch alles offen ist alles im fluss ist
dass man mal ein team hat das verhandeln
kann für cdu und csu und deswegen wird
man heute auch eine solche wahl treffen
die beiden parteivorsitzenden werden
gleich erstmal diesen vertrag
unterzeichnen danach ist ja geregelt
dass sowohl cdu wie csu abgeordnete den
neuen bundestags
fraktionschef wählen die csu natürlich
ihren eigenen schiff von der
landesgruppe das haben sie schon hinter
sich gebracht und dass er dann der erste
stellvertreter ist deswegen leitet er
auch die wahl nur soviel dazu jetzt ist
es so dass im vorfeld der ein oder
andere zum beispiel norbert röttgen
gesagt lasst uns doch bitte heute nur
erstmal so lange wählen wie wir noch
verhandeln ob wir eventuell doch noch an
die regierung kommen das kann ja
durchaus sein so abwegig ist das gar
nicht denn das grüne und fdp sich
einigen das wird in diesen tagen immer
so vorausgesetzt vor vier jahren haben
wir sehen das hat nicht geklappt also
warten wir mal ab wie das kommt und dann
wenn das vorbei ist und diese neue
regierung stehen sollte dann braucht man
ja hier im parlament einen
oppositionschef wäre es nicht sinnvoll
so ein zwei schritte dass man zunächst
mal ralph brinkhaus nimmt und dann noch
einmal neu guckt wer ist wirklich dann
der stärke man also erste priorität
heute handlungsfähigkeit der fraktion
herstellen das karte folgen zweitens wir
haben angelegt in unserer
geschäftsordnung eine begrenzung ohnehin
auf ein jahr wenn jemand heute
beantragen sollte und die mehrheit der
meinung ist dann kann man das vielleicht
auch mal bisher reduzieren also das ist
nicht der entscheidende punkt wichtig es
wird jetzt ein nicht ein provisorium und
ein übergang sondern der
fraktionsvorsitzende gewählt der für die
fraktion spricht das ist das
entscheidende und das doppelt es ist im
interesse der ganzen der ganzen
fraktionen beider parteien und also
irgendwelche übergangslösungen und
hängepartien kann es mit der union nicht
geben armin laschet spielt ja auch noch
eine gewisse rolle er hat übrigens
diesen fraktionsvorsitz gar nicht
angestrebt da gibt es sicherlich andere
man muss jetzt mal ganz klar gucken was
im letzten jahr passiert ist in der
union da gibt es die konservativen die
friedrich merz zweimal nicht
durchgekriegt haben aber immer nur knapp
gescheitert sind die jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen aufwind haben weil sie sagen
nach 16 jahren merkel
auch jetzt nach diesem schlechten
abschneiden bei der wahl mit eher einem
merkel man wie laschet wollen wir jetzt
mal hier wieder konservativer politik
das wären für einige ostdeutsche sagen
nun ist das original friedrich merz
zurückgekehrt seit 2009 waren nicht mehr
im parlament jetzt ist er wieder da man
könnte natürlich auch sagen jeden sparen
oder ein anderer den konservativen
flügel zugehöriger den bauen wir jetzt
auch hier als oppositionschef ist das
realistisch also vieles ist denkbar aber
eins ist natürlich klar wichtig ist dass
man vor einer wahl geschlossen ist
glaube das haben wir ganz gut
hingekriegt und das wir aber nacht aber
vor allem dann wenn man ein so
schlechtes ergebnis kriegt ganz offen
auch abwägt und fragt woran das gelegen
und dass dann alle möglichen
gruppierungen damir wort dazu machen und
auch ihre ansprüche anmelden und auch
sagen wäre vielleicht besser gewesen auf
uns zu hören ich glaube auch das ist
normal und das werden wir das
diskutieren miteinander in allen gremien
in der fraktion in der in den
landesgruppen und am ende wird sich dann
vielleicht nach einer gewissen
fehleranalyse dann herausstellen dass
man vielleicht doch wieder ein bisschen
mehr konservativ werden will dass man
auf die liberalkonservativen vielleicht
auch auf die nationalkonservativen
steiger zu gehen wird das ein bisschen
wirtschaftsliberaler er wird um ein
solches ergebnis wie der fdp wie bei der
fdp jetzt künftig zu vermeiden aber das
ist ein diskussionsprozess also das
kommt nicht irgendwie von von oben von
irgendjemand über gestellt sondern das
muss in der fraktion in den parteien
greifen
und da sie haben es angesprochen
ostdeutschland michael kretschmer der
ministerpräsident von sachsen hatte
schon klipp und klar gesagt also wir
brauchen da wieder mehr klare
konservative positionen eine meinung die
im übrigen auch ich habe
sie haben sicherlich recht dass die
union sich erst mal sortieren muss
deswegen ist ja umso erstaunlicher dass
für anni markus söder so einen druck
macht das heute hier abschließend
gewählt wird für das erste jahr denn das
wäre natürlich die chance jetzt die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion auch ein
bisschen anders zu positionieren als in
den vergangenen jahren und diese chance
ist natürlich jetzt eigentlich vergeben
wenn man nur einen halben tag
beratungszeit aber gerade nicht also
gerade weil wir jetzt einen längeren
prozess auch der diskussion oder
aufarbeitung brauchen können wir jetzt
nicht das übers knie brechen und sagen
mit einer mit einer anderen entscheidung
werden jetzt da richtungen vorgezeichnet
für die nächsten jahre sondern wir
wollen jetzt und das ist alles was wir
jetzt heute vorhaben handlungsfähigkeit
der cdu/csu-fraktion und das werden wir
heute machen und wie sich das dann am
ende langer diskussionsprozesse
vielleicht nächstes jahr im märz april
im sommer
entwickelt das werden wir sehen
handlungsfähigkeit friedrich bedeutet ja
auch dass man sich heute nicht zerlegt
vorher es gibt ja viele medien melden da
geht's richtig zur sache heute sie
würden also raten bisschen diana und
heute diese entscheidung nicht zu fassen
also hervor was sie kennen doch ihre
kollegen die müssen natürlich jemand
bisschen stimmung machen und ein
bisschen so tun als ob überall
durcheinander werde klar ist wir haben
eine klare linie in der fraktion während
ist heute auch nach außen noch mal
deutlich machen und insofern sind wir
handlungsfähig und sollte die ampel
sondierung scheitern
koalitionsverhandlungen scheitern stehen
wir als cdu csu für alles zur verfügung
wäre denn eine kandidatur von einem
andern heute eigentlich sinnvoll ihrer
meinung nach
würde also ob eine kante durst sinnvoll
ist oder nicht das kann
man so nicht sagen ja also ralph
brinkhaus ist unser
fraktionsvorsitzender wenn einer meint
also dagegen kriterien muss muss er gute
gründe haben ja aber am ende kann man
natürlich niemanden davon abhalten ich
gehe allerdings nicht davon aus dass
irgendeiner dagegen kandidieren wird das
hat alexander dobrindt gerade bestätigt
er leitet die wahl bisher hat sich noch
keiner gemeldet da sind wir dann mal
gespannt sie haben es angesprochen die
das rennen ist ja eigentlich noch gar
nicht vorbei alle sagen jetzt die ampel
das ist nur noch eine frage der zeit da
müssen sich aber natürlich auch die drei
parteien erstmal einigen und das wird ja
sicherlich auch sehr schwierig werden im
bereich wirtschaft steuern fällt es mir
wahnsinnig schwer zu sehen wie da die
fdp mit den grünen zusammen gehen kann
und umgekehrt bei den umwelt plänen der
grünen 50 milliarden pro jahr weiß ich
nicht so genau wo die fdp dieses geld
wenn sie nicht steuererhöhungen machen
herr holen will also ich habe selber
schon auch sondierungen mitgemacht das
ist so sie kommen unmittelbar macht da
war natürlich mit einer hohen
emotionalität und marcel mit sehr sehr
klaren worten und sagen dass es unsere
position und das ist nicht verhandelbar
und das müsse so und nach einer gewissen
zeit wenn sich das
der pulverdampf
gelegt hat dann sehen sie ja gut wir
müssen eine handlungsfähige regierung
für dieses land schaffen wir haben eine
gewisse verantwortung wir müssen
bestimmte positionen auch verändern
vielleicht zurückstellen und da muss man
warten ob das jetzt bei der ampel den
drei parteien gelingt wenn nicht wir
haben das ja vor vier jahren gesehen da
war jamaika kurzform vom abschluss da
hat man sogar sondierungen geführt die
eigentlichen koalitionsverhandlungen war
und dazu immer gedacht hat jetzt kommen
sie raus und erklären alles in butter
lindner erklärt gescheitert also es kann
immer alles passieren
insofern ist noch nicht aller tage abend
aber jetzt werden wir mal ja die union
ist der große wahlverlierer lese ich
über alles da ist unmöglich da noch zu
spekulieren dass sie mitregieren oder
gar den regierungschef stellen aber wir
haben ja vor vier jahren erlebt die spd
hat in alle mikrofone gesagt wir müssen
uns erneuern wenige opposition niemals
mit dieser union und die
sozialdemokraten als sie gerufen wurden
waren dann staatspolitisch so
verpflichtet dass sie es gemacht haben
und ich tippe mal sollte jamaika auch
scheitern nach der ampel wenn es so wäre
beides dann wird ja union ist anderes
übrig bleiben dann muss sie unter einem
kanzler scholz ebenfalls ihre
staatspolitische verantwortung nachlegen
darüber will ich jetzt nicht spekulieren
aber eins ist völlig klar jede partei
die zu einer wahl antritt hat vor allem
wenn sie eine ehemalige volkspartei ist
ja ob spd oder cdu hat die verpflichtung
dafür zu sorgen dass eine stabilität in
diesem land besteht und
insofern kann man nie irgendetwas
ausschließen wie gesagt die ampel ist
jetzt das was sortiert wird wir stehen
für jamaika bereit wenn wir gerufen
werden und das ist der stand der dinge
sie waren natürlich wie ein parteichef
söder das ist klar aber die frage wird
denn laschet noch die chance bekommen
ihrer meinung nach auch wenn sie csu
mitglied sind die chance bekommen für
die union so etwas zu verhandeln in
welcher konstellation auch immer jamaika
das wäre vielleicht sogar gar nicht
seine schwäche er kann gut verhandeln
oder vielleicht dann in einer rucola
gut also das ist jetzt eine frage die
der kanzler der kanzlerkandidat steht ja
nicht in der verfassung irgendwie
sondern es verhandeln bei koalitionen
auch bei sondierungen die
parteivorsitzenden das ist laschet
unsere unbestritten und das sind die
fraktionsvorsitzenden also brinkhaus und
probleme und sind die generalsekretäre
und damit haben sie die sondierungsrunde
im grunde schon klar ja ich diesmal um
halten sie es für möglich weil der
landesgruppenchef dobrindt gerade sagte
diese woche ist die woche der
entscheidung auch personell dass am ende
der woche herr laschet bei der cdu
geschafft wird also da müssen sie die
cdu geraten also ich habe mich noch nie
in innere angelegenheiten der cdu
eingemischt unsere schwesterpartei weiß
was sie tut hoffe ich